اذا مشاهدينا كل هذا ومعركه الجو لم تبدا
بعد واوكرانيا وروسيا تتحضران لها مع
اقتراب الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب وفق
صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه وهنا لابد لنا
اذا مشاهدينا من التعرف على قوه السلاح
الجويه الروسيه الذي لم تستخدمه موسكو رغم
مروري عام على الحرب نتحدث اذا عن القوه
الجويه الروسيه التي تحتل المرتبه الثانيه
على مستوى العالم من حيث عدد الطائرات
والافراد العاملين بعد القوه الجويه
الامريكيه فلنتعرف على اهم المقاتلات
الروسيه تمتلك روسيا مشاهدينا العديد من
المقاتلات الحديثه والتي تتمتع ايضا
بقدرات التخفي عن شاشات الرادار منها
مقاتلات سو سبعه وخمسين الحديثه وكذلك
مقاتلات سوق 57 الحديثه كذلك والمقاتله
بالاضافه الى طرز متنوعه ومختلفه اخرى
لدينا كذلك سبعه وخمسين تعتبر
من اوسيه المقاتله وتاتي بتصميم شبيه
بباقي مقاتلات الصوخوي لكنها مزوده بخاصيه
الاختفاء وهي نسخه مطوره عن طائرات الجيل
الرابع وهي تطوير كذلك لطائره سوخوي خمسه
على ذكر هذه الطائره دعونا نتعرف عليها
ونشاهدها هنا 35 اذا تمثل هذه
المقاتله نسخه محدثه ومطوره من سوخوي سبعه
وعشرين وهي طائره متقدمه من طائرات الجيل
الرابع لكنها ليست من الجيل الخامس بحسب
خبراء عسكريين غربيين ويمكن تزويد الطائره
باسلحه تصل زينتها الى اكثر من ثمانيه
الاف كلغ نذهب الى طائره اخرى هي طائره
ميغ 31 بام هذه الطائره الروسيه تشكل
العمود الفقري لسلاح الجو الروسي وتتمتع
بمزايا دفاعيه متقدمه وقدرات على مهاجمه
اهداف بريه معاديه كذلك الى جانب سرعتها
الفائقه والتحليق على ارتفاعات عاليه جدا
لكن مشاهدينا ورغم هذه المقاتلات المتطوره
لدى موسكو الا ان الاخيره تتردد كثيرا في
استخدامها والسبب هنا بحسب خبراء ان هذه
المقاتلات المتطوره تستخدم ذخيره سوفياتيه
قديمه وبالتالي يتطلب الامر ان تطير على
علو منخفض لتصيب تلك الذخائر اهدافها
كونها قديمه الطراز والامر الذي يعرضها
لخطر الرادارات والمضادات الاوكرانيه